but his score right now is it one to one
hey guys welcome to Rissa fury
I'm your host Kelsey cook and I'm joined
by Sam trip yes and this is actually not
the first time that you and I have
played each other yeah man I found out
your foods ball royalty you come from
Hall of Famers yes my mom is in the
first of all Hall of Fame yes okay I
love Hall of Famers oh my god this is so
comfortable so we played each other and
just for fun but I was there to like
actually compete we were in Las Vegas
that's a big tournament where legends
are made I want D really bit Oh barely
barely
oh she bought three not fit it's
ridiculous gay feminism well I don't
want to embarrass you in front of your
community so I threw it I threw the
match oh my gosh she's gonna have to
explain away why this chizz only
good-looking guy just came in and just
lit her up do you feel like you learned
anything from playing yeah I learned
that it's cutthroat it is obviously
these are weapons people are using
Kroenke punch yeah yeah people don't
[ __ ] around in fatality right yes
exactly do you think it's gonna go any
differently this time yeah I'm gonna
light you up and just let you know like
what you should have gotten the first
time I'm so excited no you're gonna talk
so much [ __ ] yeah so much better when I
destroy you
regulation we're gonna play standard
game first person to five that sound
good yeah no pressure Sam no pressure at
all okay oh man
we're already deep this is exactly where
I want you how's that going so far oh
that's all probably play I blow you into
a little sleep okay I like comebacks who
wants to just win straight up that's
sure
is there a Michael Jordan of foosball
yeah Tony's freedom and Oh tell me about
Tony's for me
Tony's got long hair sometimes sweatband
later Florida and just has an RV and he
just travels the country and goes to
every tournament and
it's first and just takes all the money
if you ask me to describe what I thought
the Michael Jordan of foosball beat I
would say all headband long hair for
Eddie Florida Florida 100% Florida yes
there's something wrong with my sticks
your stick
oh man god yes
whiff Can I grab your I can't even grab
your rod sounded uncomfortable oh yes
just like I planned you're not as bad as
I remember I didn't seize the moment on
it that's bull ah man this is ridiculous
if you become like the greatest foosball
player what kind of like economic
bracket can you get to um it's like just
above being a comedian that's really
pretty bleak okay let's just start from
no you can't even do that
you're so Patania Oh boom I got one take
your point yeah I'm gonna take two my
Jimmy worked oh yeah now if it bleeds I
can kill it
let's go oh oh oh man so close so close
to my help
yes oh man I'm getting better
[Applause]
yes blocking it is a win for me it is
it's exciting I'm happy yeah when did
you get into this yeah so my parents met
playing in a professional filter so your
mom was a foosball or before she met
your dad yes they both were playing
separately they met at a tournament so
like I literally wouldn't exist if it
weren't for Facebook so after a big
tournament they just made you just they
just I guess boned on a table in here I
am
man that is the greatest story ever are
they both Hall of Famers my mom is the
one who's in the Hall of Fame oh that's
gonna really hurt
he doesn't really compete as much
anymore he's still really good but he do
he is he plays trumpet professionally
[Applause]
Hall of Fame mom and a trumpeter as a
parent that's great
and he's a slam poetry champion and an
international yo-yo man oh you guys just
got big into weird ass [ __ ] is that what
this is yeah oh yeah oh man that was
exhilarating man I just can't you can't
rest that counted it was in there I saw
it there he's in there oh thank you Paul
yes Paul we haven't stopped oh my gosh
she's embarrassed for you she's upset by
this okay so the gloves are off
friendship is over I guess it's killer B
come on man come on dude you can't oh
yes I'm blocking myself again I'm
blocking all the time come on give it to
me often man there's no god there's no
God okay this is it samus's was this for
a win nope not today not today holla
feel that is brutal so what you get to
do now though we're talking about my mom
yeah Hall of Fame baseball champion buff
you get to FaceTime with her and tell
her like what the problem is you think
yeah I shouldn't give you some point
what do you think the problem is I just
don't think you're good enough to beat
me expert
five sub champ I'm just taking a beating
from your daughter yes that's all she's
doing this middle push is there anything
like psychologically I could say to her
can I tell her she's adopted just
between us just say that she won't know
and now get in her head and then at the
end I'll tell it was a lie or something
thank you thank you I appreciate
believing in me thank you very much
we're going to pick a handicap to try
and make it a little bit easier for you
to vote yeah you're so cocky you're so
cocky here we go handicap boom Sam can't
swear for the whole game or else that's
what I get I get more it's a handicap on
me okay I start with four points let's
do yeah Sam gets to start with four
points meaning if he scores even one
point he will win but he's not allowed
to swear the whole time and if he swears
I automatically get a point all right
I'm in okay god damn it I can work clean
I've done several late-night sets on
television I work clean all the time so
are you getting your ass kicked what
happened oh man that won't bring out
anger okay so I'm giving you four he's
getting four points it's gonna be great
if you don't win do you understand how
embarrassing this is gonna be for you
I'm not afraid okay
wait hahaha no you have to wait until oh
no no I don't have to do anything I
don't have to do anything
it's win at all costs I don't care okay
come on man come on man come on man you
got nothing you got nothing
garbage take oh come on Oh
Pollyanna I'm sorry without almost a
five
that came out she's us sneak attack hey
it didn't work they work I can do
whatever I want I'm not allowed to swear
this is insanity this man that sucks oh
come on thank you
this is so [ __ ] okay it's got a
point okay this is for for oh man oh man
I'm genuinely nervous right now
[Music]
the world has been shot central cook
[Applause]
I'll take it any way I could get it
crazy the worst feeling oh so much I
dream about one dude like everyone said
it was never gonna happen that you know
what but I trained and I cared and I
just focused and I put it into the
universe and I said however you're the
[ __ ] worst to not go through this
part again
I'm so excited dude these are happiest
day in my life
I don't know that says about me but man
it is awesome oh yeah yeah there's a
third round what's the damn it
so this is round three final round
sudden death we're gonna play to you
ball so to ball is where we both are the
same time start with the ball here you
started with the ball there you have to
score both balls in order to get a point
/ 5 square one you score one it's a wash
okay if I win yes
I'm gonna do your makeup because I need
some redemption after you [ __ ] my face
up on stand-ups doing makeup yeah we
worried me a [ __ ] mustache and I
looked like a dragon another horrible
dude dragons are hot that's why everyone
loves Game of Thrones people [ __ ]
dragons oh it's a big thing that's a big
fetish what's the score right now is it
one to one ah yes okay well you know
what man I'm tired of this one-on-one
stuff I'm gonna bring in a little backup
please welcome to the show a man I
helped make his career in Hollywood my
good friend the Latino Hammer el magical
everybody
aller nothing yeah watch out use in this
favor it's a very busy busy busy busy
man I just happened to be upstairs he's
not really bringing me in wearing your
mom so uh are you good
she's worthless this is my worst sort of
bar if we're like ranking like do you
know basement bar games or whatever
category this falls into yeah I am not
good at this here we go so this is
intense
this is winner takes all yeah to ever
scores two balls first
okay what's your advice we each you know
cheating those am told you have to
people no cheating
I'm Cooley so set your set your ball
where you want okay no two bows she
balls okay ready
whoa okay okay yeah just focus on that
and I'll just just bring the pain okay
one two three go oh yes yes yes yes
that's a zero back the hero I can't
believe you scored that quick nobody's
gonna move this guy back in like this
okay you break my finger [ __ ] oh
man what happens feels so good to be two
grown men oh yeah Oh beautiful dance all
right sorry oh man thanks I'll see ya
good luck thanks for the confidence I am
ready to pay my debt what look are we
going for I think
do like a night I mean I don't like the
Vegas strip whatever you think you're
supposed to do don't do that that win is
all whoa whoa whoa what are you doing
this is called lipstick not cheek stick
but you look really pretty
I feel pretty of wrists of fury
I'm the drag queen of foosball do you
feel good I feel great do you feel like
you did better against me this time than
when we played the first time yeah I
feel like my hard work has finally paid
off
good luck to all the future combatants
she's nasty
please follow sound Tripoli I mean just
give him something and he needs it all
right I feel like I should shake your
hand yeah